[Music]
on this thursday night the waterlogged
west coast gets drenched again
after a reprieve rain returns to bc and
anxiety rises i fear for the little
animals right and in atlantic canada
taking stock after torrential rain plus
a dramatic rescue we were basically
completely surrounded by water in all
sorts some stability in the military
canada's acting top soldier gets named
to the job full time the conservatives
price tag for this campaign studio do
you think that was money well spent how
much it cost the party plus what the
tories bought with taxpayer money and
getting back to the beatles
what a new documentary series about the
fab four reveals
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with extreme weather
and the damage to parts of atlantic
canada and british columbia on the south
coast of bc it is raining heavily again
one of a parade of storms forecast for
the coming days areas that flooded last
week are being closely watched there is
some good news the main route through
the fraser valley the trans-canada
highway in abbotsford has reopened for
the first time in 10 days and bc
officials said today the main commercial
route from vancouver to the rest of the
country the coquihalla highway won't
reopen until the end of january about 20
sites are damaged or washed out five
bridges destroyed
crews are working on putting in
temporary bridges but repairs are
dependent on the weather
farmers in the sumas prairie area are
trying to clean up and assess after the
devastation there worried about what
fresh storms will bring
our coverage begins with heather
europe's west in abbotsford where a
flood watch is now in place heather
yeah donna flood watch is in place for
both sumac and the south coast as you
can see it is raining very heavily here
it has been since early this morning and
those heavy rains are only expected to
continue in the coming days
after a week of chaos and devastation
brian cockrell is just focused on
keeping the animals on the farm safe and
dry the experience was almost horrifying
i did try to get out of here after
getting the animals set up the property
on the sumas prairie fared better than
many in the area the water came close to
the house and barn but the major
structures did not flood still he
worries about what the next several days
of rain will bring i fear for the little
animals right like
getting him up here and then having no
shelter for him in the rain you know we
might be on a little island but i don't
think the water will come this
elevation here more than a million
chickens lived on farms in the area when
flooding began last week at least 100
thousand are believed to have died along
with around 500
cows down the road volunteers have been
working long hours to clean up from last
week's flood hopeful the progress made
so far won't be undone if waters rise a
second time we're hoping there's not as
many millimeters as they're saying and
but we're just going to keep keep
cleaning and keep repairing and we'll
see what god has in store but as
volunteers work to clean up this church
here all of their neighboring properties
remain under water and with so much rain
in the forecast in the coming days it's
not clear when things will dry up enough
for people here to come back
with the main dyke breech almost fully
repaired abbotsford is as ready as it
can be
and although highway one is back open
east of abbotsford officials say drivers
should be prepared with so much rain in
the forecast the risk of washouts on the
highway has not passed we hope and
expect
that highway one will will be able to
remain open but we will be constantly
monitoring its performance and if
necessary we may have to close the
highway again because safety is always
our first priority
solid signs of progress but the cleanup
is far from done
although traffic is flowing again on
highway one drivers can only get as far
as chilliwack before encountering more
restrictions it will be months before
all of the damage done to bc highways
can be repaired more than 200 sites have
been affected including 130 kilometers
of the coquihalla donna
so much work to do heather yorick's
western abbotsford bc thanks
the same storm system pummeled bc's
north coast last night cleanup efforts
are underway in prince rupert a 17-hour
drive northwest of vancouver strong
winds knocked down power lines sent
debris flying and caused a container
ship to run aground the vessel has since
been refloated and reports indicate
there's no significant damage
and across the country in eastern nova
scotia and southwestern newfoundland
cleanup efforts are also underway
tonight after the torrential rainfall
there the damage is still being assessed
and it is extensive roads bridges and
culverts are washed out and communities
cut off ross lord has the story plus
details of a remarkable rescue
since they moved into a yurt by the
river three years ago melissa and chris
battist and their dog have encountered
plenty of bad weather comfortably
removed when the brook overflows
not this time it was just startling to
see
how fast the water came up in a matter
of minutes but we were basically
completely surrounded by water in all
sides the rcmp came to the rescue
organizing a helicopter airlift they
spent
12 hours or so trying to get helicopters
to us all's well that ends well for all
three evacuees
elsewhere the focus is on rebuilding in
cape breton nova scotia the storm
destroyed sections of the cabot trail
with some residents cut off from
emergency health care fixing this mess
is crucial it's
getting the roads repaired and reopened
to get access to the vital services and
vital links back in newfoundland the man
who drove his truck over the
trans-canada highway as it was crumbling
away is still a bit bewildered still
kind of uh trying to figure out how i
made it to the other side i guess before
i even had a chance to slow down or
anything i was already kind of into it
and next time all the airplanes were
going off
and
that's when i kind of bounced back at
the hole and landed on the other side
returning shattered roadways to normal
will take days or weeks
for some people restoring peace of mind
could take much longer
ross lord global news halifax
there's a little more certainty about
the leadership of the canadian military
general wayne ayer is no longer acting
chief of the defence staff he's been
given the job full-time mercedes
stevenson is with me from ottawa
mercedes was the announcement from the
prime minister's office a surprise to
anyone
donna it was certainly a long time in
coming but it was perhaps the least
surprising chief of the defense staff
announcement we have ever seen he has
been of course in the role for many
months now ever since admiral art
macdonald had to step aside under
allegations of sexual misconduct he's
been in this job and we saw signals a
few weeks ago when he was promoted to
full general that this was likely going
to be his fate wayne ayer is someone
who's very highly regarded inside the
canadian armed forces some call him the
warrior monk because he's so focused on
security issues and understanding them
and really uh intellectual and academic
person he's perceived as being very
bright and ethical but we have seen him
struggle at times with managing the
turmoil in the canadian armed forces
however a lot of the survivors who i've
spoken to in survivors groups do believe
he's trying to take it seriously it
appears the government wanted to wait
until they had a new minister of
national defense in place before they
made the announcement and of course a
general airs priority will be reforming
the culture in the military at this time
and mercedes what about admiral art
macdonald who had the top job a while
ago then stepped aside because of
allegations tried to get his job back
what happens to him now
well you remember that letter he wrote
which was quite shocking to the general
and flag officers of the canadian armed
forces arguing that he should be the cds
uh the government had to do something
about this today minister anand says
that art macdonald remains on leave and
he retains his rank but he has lost the
confidence of the government and is no
longer the chief of the defense staff
this is what she had to say about the
letter that he penned
the letter that uh admiral mcdonald
wrote was shocking it was unacceptable
and
i look forward to working with wayne air
in that position
it will be up to the canadian armed
forces to decide what happens next
whether um admiral mcdonald retires or
what his future is we're waiting still
to hear back from his lawyers on that
but that's the latest that we have donna
okay mercedes stevenson in ottawa thanks
the federal green party has selected a
new interim leader amita kutner is a 30
year old astrophysicist from british
columbia they are the youngest and the
first transgender person to lead a
national political party kutner who ran
against adami paul for the leadership
last year faces the task of
reinvigorating the green party which has
struggled with infighting plummeting
support and financial problems kutner
will lead the greens until a new leader
is elected next year
now to russia and a disaster in a coal
mine at least 52 people are reported to
have died it happened in southwestern
siberia russian media is reporting coal
dust caught fire filling the mine with
smoke authorities say nearly 300 people
were in the mine at the time most were
able to escape but dozens were trapped
officials have told russian media there
is no chance of finding survivors among
the dead or three rescuers
in europe the migrant crisis is in the
spotlight again after what is being
called the deadliest day on record in
the english channel officials now say at
least 27 people died trying to get from
france to england in a small boat among
the dead a pregnant woman and three
children both countries have agreed to
step up efforts to prevent the dangerous
crossings and stop gangs from putting
lives at risk but as crystal comancing
reports aid groups say what migrants
really need are better options
recent arrivals in england await
processing warm and safe
these asylum seekers survive the
harrowing journey across the english
channel
15
men overbought approximately 15 men
on wednesday 27 died in the freezing
waters between england and france
including three children a french
fishing boat came upon them first
crossing the channel
in this lethal way in a small boat is
not the way to come to our country
refugee aid groups agree the crossings
which are increasing are unsafe and
that's why the uk must create a better
system we need to give people the option
to claim asylum before needing to even
think about getting in the water
along the french coast there are small
camps with people of all ages from
around the world
france's president says there are
processing centers near cali and dunkirk
but people want to go to the uk
i need to make a future i need to make a
life to to bring my family to call my
family to help my family send money
everything
migrant camps are continuously
dismantled and french police with
financing from the uk patrol beaches
aid groups say enforcement efforts only
push the vulnerable into the hands and
boats of human smugglers
you'd rather die
than carry on
so it's beyond desperation it's beyond
despair that makes them undertake these
terrible journeys the deadly journey
wednesday is said to be the worst in the
history of the channel crystal gamson
global news
london
lights cameras and costs coming up how
much the federal conservative party
spent on its campaign studio
[Music]
there are some questions tonight about
the cost of a broadcast studio built for
the federal conservative party campaign
earlier this year pandemic restrictions
were still in place and leader aaron
o'toole used it to reach canadians
virtually until now conservative party
members didn't know how much it cost
mike at reports
[Music]
it was a slick state-of-the-art studio
built for aaron o'toole to beam his
message directly to canadians just
before and during the last election
multiple sources have told global news
the high-tech operation
cost 1 million dollars when asked about
it o'toole was unapologetic we knew that
justin trudeau would use
the pandemic for his political favor and
the studio was a way that we could
connect
with hundreds of thousands of people
and we continued to use it through our
party resources during the election
set up in a downtown ottawa hotel the
studio was used to hold press
conferences film fundraising videos and
to hold teletown halls instead of
heading out to more conventional
election rallies you do what you have to
do in order to reach canadians and talk
to canadians so you have to spend money
to do that if we would have been a full
pandemic election where would he go on
some members of the conservative caucus
still have questions about the strategy
and the expense do you think it was
money well spent well i think there
should be a 100 counting on part of that
accounting includes 74 000 taxpayer
dollars spent by the office of the
leader of the opposition around the time
the studio was being set up in early
2021 the expense was for video
communication and broadcast equipment
which the party says was not used for
partisan purposes yes i can assure
canadians that no money was used
public money in the election cycle
all this comes as the internal review of
the election loss continues and
questions about o'toole's leadership
remain i think the nature of the
questioning will be more
dangerous to mr o'toole because these
are loaded questions now being lobbed
over at him principally i suspect by
people who don't want him to see him
continue lead the party tim powers added
the expenses likely wouldn't be
questioned had the studio helped deliver
a conservative win
mike lacouter global news ottawa
silencing voices ahead the taliban
targets afghanistan's free press
the extended families of afghan
interpreters who supported the canadian
forces in kandahar now have a new path
to permanent residency in canada the
federal government has announced new
measures to help extended family of
those who resettled in canada between
2009 and 2012.
those people can apply starting december
9th and must have been in afghanistan on
or after july 22 of this year
it is a welcome development the taliban
is tightening its grip on power in
afghanistan new religious guidelines
were issued this week that further
restrict the role of women broadcasters
have been told to stop airing dramas and
soap operas that feature women and
female tv reporters have to wear a hijab
many have already fled the country as
jeff semple reports journalists still
there find themselves in the crosshairs
before escaping to canada in september
shigofa siddiqui spent years fighting
the taliban in afghanistan her weapons
this keyboard and her voice
siddiqi ran zantv afghanistan's first
channel staffed entirely by female
journalists
the fearless reporter regularly received
threats
one of her news anchor colleagues was
recently killed by a car bomb
even before the taliban afghan
journalists faced many risks especially
females she says but when the taliban
arrived everything got worse
as foreign journalists visiting here we
required this letter of permission from
the ministry of foreign affairs for the
taliban to be here and to talk to people
but otherwise we've been able to move
around relatively unimpeded the taliban
desperate for international aid and
recognition is trying to show a
friendlier face to foreign reporters
but afghan journalists tell a different
story
since the taliban took power in august
afghanistan's national journalists union
has reported dozens of attacks at least
seven journalists have been killed
the taliban is pretending it has changed
but they are taking revenge says this
reporter he used to work for a
nato-funded organization
my job was to produce stories to show
afghans the canadian military was good
that they were here to fight for the
people and against the taliban
terrorists we met him in kabul where
he'd spent months in hiding but last
week he escaped the country thanks to
help from a canadian organization called
journalists for human rights the
situation's pretty dire the
toronto-based group compiled a list of
450 afghan journalists whom it says meet
canada's criteria to come as refugees
but the canadian government recently
quietly changed those rules to only
accept those who are already outside of
afghanistan what was your reaction to
that confusion and frustration
one of the things that has been
really
challenging through this process is the
communication piece and another concern
the more afghan journalists escape the
country the fewer are left to tell the
true story of life under taliban rule
jeff semple global news kabul
old tunes new insight what a new
documentary reveals about the beatles
if you thought you knew everything about
the musical legends the beatles think
again there's another eight-hour
documentary series about them it
includes footage of the band that hasn't
aired before the four of them rehearsing
and bantering the kind of
fly-on-the-wall stuff beatles fans can't
get enough of eric sorensen has some
hints about what the documentary reveals
they were a momentous phenomenon in
modern culture the beatles the fab four
produced one hit
after another
after another let it be
so musically gifted so prolific so
influential
it's hard to believe the beatles era
lasted little more than six years
now we're gonna take the beatles i'll be
quiet are you enjoying our conversation
for beatles fans and history buffs a new
documentary captures three weeks up
close with john paul george and ringo in
1969. another bright day morning camera
still having fun
but showing signs of the breakup to come
how many have we already recorded good
enough no
it's really it's great stuff director
peter jackson had 56 hours of raw film
thanks to michael lindsey hogg's let it
be documentary 50 years ago the
documentary is draining to a halt
grinding to a home something is taking
off
here we go
most remarkable is getting to see and
hear musical genius at work what could
it be paul
something in the way
what attracted me just say whatever
comes in the head each time attracts me
like a cauliflower until you get the
word which became of course attracts me
like
[Music]
these are songs that we know so so well
but back when this film was being shot
these songs were still in their
embryonic stage and we get to watch them
all come together the film has new
insights yoko ono it seems was not the
cause of discontent in fact at that time
george was the one ready to walk out i
think we should forget the whole idea of
this show so before they went their
separate ways there were still songs to
create
unguarded moments and creative tensions
abound in the film but when the beatles
collaborate it is spellbinding
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen it is
thanksgiving day in the united states
and to honor our neighbors we leave you
with a new york holiday tradition the
macy's thanksgiving day parade was back
in full helium force today for the 95th
year the giant balloons and the big
crowds took to the streets of manhattan
it began back in 1924 a few new balloons
have been added since then and it's
rarely been cancelled thanks for
watching jeff sample will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow and i'll see you on
saturday for the new reality take care
of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
you